Speaker 1: Republicans have seen the polling
and they are terrified that running strongly
against all abortions is going to crush them
in November.
So we have to understand now on the left,
the Republicans have have seen the polling.
They know the numbers in the aftermath of
the repeal of Roe v Wade by the Supreme Court,
the overturning of Roe v Wade by the Supreme
Court.
We have seen a dramatic shift in polling for
these November midterm elections.
And I've told you that we're going to look
at the numbers tomorrow or Thursday.
But the odds that Democrats keep the Senate
are now roughly 2 to 1.
Democrats still expected to lose the House,
but by a smaller margin than at any point
during this midterm election cycle.
And much of it much of it is because of the
anger about Roe v Wade being overturned and
the fundamental right to an abortion in most
cases disappearing.
Republicans are aware of this, and we are
now seeing a number of different Republicans,
either in interviews or on their websites,
change or certainly restructure the way that
they talk about abortion, some of them removing
altogether their anti-choice stances from
their respective websites.
So last week, I brought you the story of this
Democrat in Michigan who won in a swing district
in a special election by focusing in on abortion
just straight up one.
And it's abundantly clear that this is a big
risk for Republicans.
We now have a clip from this is from yesterday
or maybe the day before yet?
No, this is from yesterday.
This is John.
I believe it's pronounced Odie D might be
day.
This is the Republican Senate candidate in
Colorado.
He went on Fox News and he made it very clear
he supports women's right to choose an abortion
early in the pregnancy and even later when
there are particular circumstances.
Take a listen to this, a very different sounding
Republican.
Speaker 2: Martha, thanks for having me on
today.
I really appreciate.
Speaker 3: It.
You know, your race was very interesting.
One to watch.
You beat a candidate who was more of a Trump
supporter.
You are sort of running in a more moderate
lane.
And yet your opponent, the current Senator,
Michael Bennet, is is looking to sort of peg
you that way a little bit more.
Here's an example in an ad that dropped on
Friday.
Watch us.
Speaker 1: Dropped.
Speaker 3: It makes the race for Senate even
more important.
Michael Bennet has always fought to protect
a woman's right to make her own health care
decisions.
But Joe O'Dea opposes the law protecting abortion
access in Colorado.
So we want to give you a chance to respond
to that, because clearly the Roe v Wade decision
is becoming a factor in races all across the
country.
We're going to see a lot of ads like that.
Are they accurately portraying your view on
this, sir?
Speaker 2: Oh, that that ads dishonest.
It's at best.
I came out early on in this election and said
that I supported a woman's rights early on
in the pregnancy and even later on, you know,
with mitigating circumstances.
So I've been very vocal about that issue,
ran my primary on that, and we ended up winning.
Speaker 1: You know, so this is very interesting
because I can't tell you that if Joe O'Dea
makes it, makes it to the Senate that he would
actually be a pro-choice vote.
I can't say what all we all we can look at
is what he's saying today.
And he has made, I believe, the correct calculation
that at this point when it came.
To Democrats and even moderate Republicans.
It is not a good idea to take these wacky
anti-choice views in a state like Colorado
when you are running in the Senate now, if
you are running in a particular red district
for the House in Alabama, it's a very different
story.
But he's correctly sort of taking the pulse
of the electorate in Colorado and the pulse
of the country.
And if he is going to defeat Bennet and get
to the Senate with that electorate and the
entire state of Colorado as the voting constituency,
he can't be a wacky, anti-choice or now he
may be an anti-choice or personally, but he
has made the correct calculation that he can't
really be running that way.
This is not super unique.
We're seeing instances of this elsewhere as
well in Arizona.
Four days ago, Blake Masters right wing nut
backtracks on abortion and scrubs his campaign
website.
This is all from the last week.
So Blake Masters realizing I might want to
ease up on some of the anti-abortion stuff.
Another example here.
Republican congressional candidate and state
Senator Tom Barrett totally removed the values
section of his campaign website, which touted
his anti-abortion position and history with
the pro-life movement.
Also making the calculation that, listen,
even if these are my views and even if this
is how I'm ultimately going to vote, if the
people elect me, I don't necessarily want
to be promoting this and making it front and
center.
This is a very important shift.
Now, what are what are the going to be the
substantive repercussions of such a shift?
We actually don't know yet because part of
it is, are these Republicans actually becoming
mildly pro-choice or are they just lying because
they see that that's what they need to do
in order to get themselves elected?
And it won't actually change anything if and
when they do.
That's a it's a predictive question.
We're just guessing.
We don't have the answer.
But the fact that they're feeling the need
to change their messaging on this issue is
already extraordinarily important.
Let me know what you make of this.
Are these candidates is there going to be
a wave of pro-choice Republicans or are these
merely the lies they're willing to tell in
order to get themselves elected?
Because they've sort of put their finger to
the wind and feel the way that it's blowing.
Let me know.
Tomorrow night, 6 p.m. Eastern, it is finally
here.
I know many of you have been waiting for so
long.
It is the David Pakman show members only town
hall.
We will open up the phone lines exclusively
to our members tomorrow at 6 p.m. Eastern.
Every member is welcome to participate and
chat with me.
It will be streaming live on YouTube, Twitch
and Facebook, so everybody is free to watch.
But we will just be inviting our members to
participate in the town hall.
Still time to sign up at join pacman dot com.